yeah all the pocky people here
you don't need to make it any hotter
we're good
we're fine this this can be it
this went to 11. leave it out
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans and it is that time the
date on my calendar that i've learned to
both love and dread it's the pocky one
chip challenge which somehow someway
just gets crazier every single year and
if you've been watching us you know the
pocky one chip challenge misery loves
company we have to bring a guest and
today we have a very good one tony hawk
back in the building
he's a bonafide skateboarding legend the
pioneer of the 900 the man behind the
best video game series ever a
philanthropist an entrepreneur and
someone who knows food better than most
anyone i know tony hawk welcome back to
the hot ones thank you i think
appreciate it
so you were actually one of our earliest
guests way back in the hot ones wild
wild west days what do you remember
about that trip against the gauntlet it
was a live event at complexcon and have
you been experimenting with spicy food
in a bigger way since then
well i remember it being the first live
show you did yep so i felt very
self-conscious because we had an
audience there and also i knew that it
was just going to run in real time
so it was hard to get through the bites
and yeah not look like you're just
sitting there chewing and chewing
chewing forever so i remember that but
also that seventh or eighth wing being
way hotter than anything else yeah and
that hasn't changed by the way and you
gave me uh you gave me a hot sauce as a
gift i can't say that i've tried to
explore hotter things since then and so
going into this
i feel a little ill-prepared but you're
in good hands together we will take on
this pocky chip and we will live to tell
the tale at the other side
[Music]
two years ago we had lil yachty on the
first time that he ever tried hot sauce
was actually on hot ones and then the
second time that he'd never eaten
anything spicy was when he took on the
one chip challenge and we actually have
a clip of that to show you kind of what
he was going through not to psych you
out or lead the witness but here's a
clip from yachty
oh my
oh my god
i can't i can't
um that's not encouraging but he lived
to tell a tale so right and and like i
said he'd never had anything spicy
before until that so that was a reaction
that we could expect how we'll react
today though only time will tell it is
time to bring in the boxes
all right tony so this is the sixth year
of the pocky one chip challenge the most
shocking version yet what you have here
with this chip is carolina reaper and
scorpion pepper independently two of the
spiciest peppers in the world and this
year's chip we're combining them and
then as a unique twist for the 2022
version this chip actually turns your
tongue blue
is that the proof you need yeah i voted
let's pop this box open and see what we
have inside
all right so first things first a very
breathable soft t-shirt practical when
you're eating something never sweating
it out as spicy as this chip yep
absorbent okay soft comfortable
then you have oh some chips here
i have a haunted ghost pepper same
fiery chile lamone
tease the palette let me just um
very nice
enjoyable in a way that i don't think
what is deeper in this box
here we have a bucket hat
to go with the t-shirt
and then
very important i haven't i haven't
earned this yet
then very important
you have latex gloves
and that's because
in this box
we have the chip
in the coffin which i know very well
i'm obviously not a surgeon
nailed it tony nailed it okay
[Music]
there's a lot of disclaimers here oh you
know what
it's 25 calories i might have to bounce
you do and in addition to that we have
do not eat if you're sensitive to spicy
foods we're good there allergic to
peppers think we're good there wash your
hands with soap and do not touch your
eyes or other sensitive areas that's a
good note very good note
are you ready to pop this thing open
okay
all right tony as someone who's done
some of the most extreme things on the
planet and broken almost every bone
known to medical science are you ready
to pop
open the coffin on the pocky one chip i
think so all right here we go
never an easy this is the first
challenge is opening this with gloves on
there we go
oh how cute little coffin with giant
warnings i remember this they have the
inserts in here
just like last just like a liability
waiver we have to sign them
i think we already signed that okay
all right well this is nice to get a
commemorative uh
poster here i crushed
the one chip challenge
if
if and when
then we get this right yep if and when
if and when and then they have sort of
like a tiered thing on the back of here
how long can you last before you short
circuit one minute
powerless 10 minutes powerful
30 minutes supercharged one hour
invincible so
if i break a minute i'll feel pretty
good about that okay if one of us breaks
down then the other one
yeah it goes here's here's what i think
i need guidance
set a minute time and i'll leave it up
to you so you think how long can we go
without reaching for the water okay
without reaching for the milk can we go
five minutes
three minutes
[Laughter]
tony you keep going down that's fine
with me you set the bar you set the bar
for us geez uh i i think five minutes is
a huge goal five minutes we're taking a
big swing everybody five minutes we eat
this chip no water somewhere between
powerless and powerful i'm happy i would
like to lean towards powerful yeah but
are you going you're opening it so i'm
opening this thing up and immediately or
reaper big time coming through
wow
all right and as you pull that out
immediately the color is distressing
it looks
so coated yeah and it smells i almost
had a pavlovian response to that smell
it took me right back to last year
okay is that good not good
well you survived last year i did i did
make it i did make it it looks like the
remnants of of a terrible house fire it
is exactly one that was just so hot
everything melted yep that's exactly
what it looks like and then curious to
see how this is gonna turn the tongue
blue but
so we'll eat this chip when does the
time start the second this breaks the
plane
it starts ugh is it wrong to
go two bites
three bites no that's not wrong there's
no wrong way to go about this except the
whole thing is wrong but like there's no
what about little pieces over the course
of a couple hours that i think would be
the worst idea okay
[Laughter]
you ready
i think so all right one
two
three jump
[Music]
all right
have you swallowed yet
just followed
how you swallow without any water
i know
that's part of the challenge
the power
and powder
i can't swallow it
oh
i got the hiccups
just immediately
how's that timer doing
derek where are we at
all right one minute down one minute
down
i'm feeling a little flush i always
forget about this you know
like you go through it
and you're like
i'm never
doing this again
and then
it happens
and you just do it
it is extraordinarily hot on my tongue
yeah wait till you swallow
it's it's gone
i did the thing uh blue tarp
but you're very composed i have to say
i'm trying
i kind of wish i wasn't so i don't know
all the milk like when i look at it
i see why this is such a challenge
yeah
i feel like my tongue's starting to not
work i know my throat isn't ah
into almost like a head high like i'm
like light-headed right now
um
i would very much like the milk yeah me
too
we made it two minutes do you want to go
in
up to you i'm following you
uh
how do you know like
you've done some extreme things are we
doing an interview right now
i'm just curious they're gonna have like
deep thoughts your skateboarding career
do you think it's given you an ability
to compartmentalize pain in any way like
yes in a moment like this
not to let it overwhelm yes
are we at three minutes
just 90 seconds to go okay
five minutes
five minutes we can make it i'm not
gonna be the one that breaks down oh man
i wanna
my nose is running i'm gonna wipe my
nose but be careful not with the gloves
yeah definitely
um feel like all of my senses
have
stopped
functioning and gone to my head and my
mouth like
all hands on deck there's trauma up here
yeah
that we are approaching the finish line
slowly
surely
we're getting there
okay
give me a countdown
ten
nine eight
seven
six five four
three
two
cheers one
cheers tony [ __ ] oh we [ __ ] did it
i'd like to say that help but that
helped actually that helps
well there you have it we're good now
we're fine tony hawk
taking on the challenge like a pro
living to tell the tale
for the second time taking on a hot
one's gauntlet how are you feeling
um word of advice to anyone if something
gets stuck in your teeth
get that out immediately
because i just got a little bit
and it's like started over again well
you did it
you made it
and if you at home if you're watching at
home and you're like oh what those guys
are going through that's what i'd like
to do i'd love to do that just like this
if you want to get your hands
on one of these chips visit pocky chips
or pocky.com
to get a list of retailers locally in
the us and this year now in canada the
most extreme challenge yet don't forget
the hashtag
onechipchallenge
don't forget to show off your blue
tongue
is there anyone that does this to try to
reel off all those things he just said
after you do this that's the second one
chip challenge one chip challenge bonus
good luck bye
all right folks i'm out
[Music]
oh my god
[Applause]
the aftermath is rough ma'am
thank you but that's interesting you
think it's a skateboarding thing that's
like taught you like yeah well
having just been through the trauma i
was through i broke my leg
um in march
and having to wait for an ambulance
with
my bones sticking out over here
i was at my ramp so there's no ambulance
close by oh my god so i knew the
ambulance and then i had to convince
them to take me to a further hospital
because i know the head of vr there so
they're like all right it's going to be
like 40 minutes i don't care
i don't care and just
holding out for that
taught me so much more of what i'm
capable of you know
how long from when you broke your leg to
when you finally got to your friend in
the er
it was it was probably a couple hours
hour and a half two hours
that was a bad day
yeah so like what's the one chip
challenge
it was more it it was that weight it was
that weight to
get something to drink
yeah like that it took you back to that
thing because you're like all right just
five more minutes ten more minutes yeah
exactly that
i kept asking michael what freebie eggs
are we at